couillard bon jour on vous rejoins dans
votre auto bus de campagne et vous êtes
en mauricie merci nous donner quelques
minutes bonjour ce avec un peu partout
en région vous avez des candidats qui
sont en danger vous pourriez perdre des
circonscriptions en région
comment vous expliquez vous qui avez
sillonné le québec depuis plusieurs
semaines qu'ils aient autant de gens
mécontents et madame galipeau bon je
vous dirais les verts je serais pas
surprise le vote en disant ce que je
vois également des circonscriptions
qu'on va gagner et ce que j'entends
quand je rencontre des gens partout au
québec c'est oui effectivement le québec
va mieux
oui ma région vaut mieux on ne crée de
l'emploi les budgets sont équilibrés il
ya de l'argent pour l'éducation la santé
des gens l'apprécient
je pense que notre message d bien
entendu et la comparaison pour nous elle
est simple une performance financière
économique vraiment extraordinaire d'un
côté soutien des services publics et de
l'autre côté un chaos financier qui
tient pas la route et pas de réponses
aux questions mais vous savez qu'en
région votre réforme en santé affaire a
fait des trous en fait dans les services
dire qu'on regroupant les services des
gens maintenant que sont obligés de
faire des kilomètres pour passer un
examen pour obtenir un traitement ya du
travail à faire comment vous allez
régler ce problème qui fait qui fait mal
aux régions je le sais moi même je suis
au lac saint jean puis on à l'hôpital de
roberval à l'hôpital de dolbeau
mistassini intégré dans un grand
ensemble régional qui assure la
continuité des soins dont le centre de
contrôle principal et un sac n'est autre
fois chicoutimi la question de la
représentativité et de l'impact des
petits milieux c'est quelque chose qui
moi me préoccupe d'abord comme premier
ministre mais également comme citoyenne
région j'en ai parlé à gertrude bourdon
avec les conditions de travail des
hommes et des femmes du réseau
ce sera quelque chose qui va effectuer à
recevoir notre attention de façon très
important je pense pas en passant que
les solutions sont très complexes s'agit
juste de trouver quelqu'un à chacun de
ces milieux là qu elle capable de faire
le lien qui est capable d'agir avec
autorité capable de répondre aux
citoyens et d'avoir une présence
constante
problème le problème le problème que je
vois des poids pour les patients les
statistiques d'accès s'améliore partout
au québec y compris dans nos régions ici
la liste d'attentes en mauricie pour un
médecin de famille à trois rivières a
baissé de 60% alors quitté les choses
s'améliorent pour les patients c'est pas
parfait encore mais on est dans la bonne
direction
ce que je trouve qu'il faut corriger et
améliorer c'est la sensation des petits
milieux comme
chez moi l'hôtel dieu de roberval et
dolbeau mistassini de faire partie du
processus décisionnel et d'avoir
quelques la quête en autorité qui peut
interagir avec la population et je crois
que là il ya quelque chose à corriger et
on voit le corriger alors on comprend
vouliez donner plus d'accès avec cette
réforme vous le disais un médecin de
famille doux et l'attenté aux urgences
mais on se retrouve aussi avec un
personnel du réseau de la santé monsieur
khouya qui est épuisé qui est démobilisé
est-ce que vous avez laissé monsieur
barek était votre ministre de la santé
allaient aussi loin et aussi vite
d'abord il fallait faire ça pour
justement assurer la continuité des
soins ceci dit je reconnais que le
personnel a été lourdement mis à
contribution en plus des soins
extraordinaires qui donne aux gens 7
jours semaine
et ça il ya bien sûr faut le mentionner
c'est aussi mathieu barrette qui a mis
en place les projets les 17 projets
actuels pour ajuster les équipes de
soins pour se débarrasser du temps
supplémentaire faut le dire ça aussi
l'autre dossier c'est le suivant c'est
améliorer la qualité de vie au travail
des hommes et des femmes qui travaillent
dans le réseau
bien sûr les infirmières également
infirmière auxiliaire préposé notamment
parce que les problèmes de pénurie de
préposés au québec pour donc rendre
cette profession plus attrayante
je sais qu'elle est difficile et on va
donner des ressources pour ça on s'est
entendu madame bourdon et moi pour qu'
il ya des ressources consacrées à
l'amélioration des soins comme toujours
mais également à l'amélioration de la
qualité de vie au travail des hommes et
des femmes qui travaillent dans nos
réseaux et c'est la même chose en
éducation passer maintenant mais
monsieur criage vous parlez de votre de
ce que vous avez appelé votre rigueur
budgétaire pendant les deux premières
années de mandat elles ont fait mal
six jours de campagne qu'est ce que vous
dites à ces gens là là dans les ch et
celle des les gens plus vulnérables les
personnes déficientes intellectuelles
personnes autistes ou même dans le
réseau de l'éducation
qu'est ce que vous dites aux personnes
vulnérables qui ont souffert de ces
compressions je leur dis d'abord que la
plus grande menace ou services publics
soir était de laisser le québec en
déficit et un ans d'être ma chronique ça
ça aurait vraiment affecté à long terme
nos services publics
je rappelle également qu'une fois
l'équilibré établi on a depuis injecté 6
milliards de dollars dans le réseau de
santé et a ajouté deux mille personnes
de plus dans nos 6 h et celle des essais
pour rien ça fait longtemps qu'on n'a
pas vu ça et on a des budgets maintenant
pour continuer à aller de l'avant en
fait le problème hockey
on fait face maintenant c'est plus le
manque de budget c'est le manque de
personnel je vous dis c'est que ça les
deux premières années quand même ça ça a
marqué les gens ça a marqué les esprits
des gens et je leur dis que si on avait
laissé le québec en déficit chronique
avec le trou énorme qui avait on serait
encore en train de parler de
compressions budgétaires
cette époque là elle est derrière nous
on a rétabli l'équilibré après environ
deux ans on a dégénéré des marges de
manoeuvre qui ont été immédiatement
injectés dans les services publics et le
prochain mandat comprend comment ce non
pas avec un problème d'équité budgétaire
avec des ressources garanti sur quatre
ans prévisible pour les résoudre santé
d'éducation est ce que ça pourrait pas
être ça monsieur couillard qui peut-être
passe pas très bien c'est à dire que
vous semblez un peu peut-être détachées
parce que on sent pas beaucoup de
compassion la danse que vous répondez à
ces gens mais madame madame galipeau
quand je parle de ça je pense aux
personnes qui sont traitées avant tout
et je pense aux conséquences que j'ai
déjà vu - lorsque j'étais en pratique
médicale d'un gouvernement qui perd le
contrôle des finances publiques
les mises à la retraite par milieu mon
infirmière deux salles d'opération qui a
débarrassé le plancher du jour au
lendemain mais patient aussi été mal
pris alors je parle constamment je pense
constamment aux patients et je répète
que pour les patients du québec
on a maintenant une horizon de
financement de la santé et de permet
d'aller plus loin en fait aussi loin
qu'on n'a jamais rêvé d'aller
et maintenant la bonne mauvaise qu'on
ait les moyens de le faire moi j'ai
connu l'époque des compressions des
déficits est complet l'époque du déficit
zéro sous un autre régime auparavant des
mêmes personnes qui maintenant nous
critiquent ils ont fait à sabrer dans
les budgets et en se débarrassant de
centaines de milliers de personnes dans
les services publics de dizaines de
milliers de personnes publiques ça veut
dire qu'il fallait le faire même
galipeau parfois quand on gouverne vous
savez il faut faire des choses
difficiles et l'alternative de laisser
les déficits rouler auraient été bien
pires croyez-moi on regarde ce qui s'est
passé au nouveau brunswick mais monsieur
prière est ce que vous craignez un
exemple comme celui là ça pourrait
arriver au québec aussi un mais vous
savez il faut se garder les comparaisons
et l'ontario sont à des situations
budgétaires radicalement différente de
celle du québec moi je suis regardé
partout ailleurs au canada comme
quelqu'un qui a réussi quelque chose
qu'on pensait pas possible retourner
complètement la situation financière du
québec
relancer l'économie créer de 115 mille
emplois au nouveau brunswick qu'ils ont
les problèmes d' impasse budgétaire
majeure et vous avez joué à noter rios
c'est la même chose on n'est pas dans le
même sens bien ça n'est pas la même
chose mais monsieur galant bengals ont
obtenu un plus grand pourcentage de voix
et moins de sièges que son adversaire ça
a donné des munitions aujourd'hui toute
la journée à l'eau aux partisans d'une
réforme du mode de scrutin vous vous
dites non pourquoi
parce que j'ai pas ça moi sur mon
échiquier sur mon plan de travail a bien
d'autres priorités
il ya beaucoup de citoyens et citoyennes
au québec que ça agite cette question là
ils veulent avant tout des meilleurs
soins des meilleurs voeux les dix
meilleures classes pour leurs enfants
des meilleurs emplois toujours un peu
plus d'argent dans leurs poches un peu
plus de temps avec leurs proches
c'est moi c'est ce sur quoi je vais me
concentrer et vous savez on a déjà eu
des situations semblables au québec lors
d'autres élections
de toute façon ça mais nous avec le même
nombre de députés parce que c'est ce qui
est prévu s'amène obligatoirement une
diminution du nombre de circonscriptions
surtout en région avec deux catégorique
députés des députés elie sur le terrain
par les citoyens et les députés des deux
listes qui viennent donc ces dons c'est
ou d'un territoire plus grand que la
région elle-même
il y aura pas d'attachés repas de
d'enracinement de ces gens là au
territoire qui représente et c'est pas
le genre de politique que je veux voir
dans nos régions alors il vrai six jours
donc qu'est ce que vous allez dire aux
gens pendant ces six jours qu'est ce qui
est essentiel selon vous comparez
d'un côté vous avez le gouvernement bien
sûr qu a tenu ses engagements qui a
présenté quatre budgets équilibrés
consécutive que générer des marges de
manoeuvre que baisser vos impôts qui
investit largement à santé en éducation
qui a engagé les gens dans ceux du
réseau là et qui nourrit l'innovation
québec
de l'autre vous avez quelqu'un qui a un
cadre financier qui ne tient pas
totalement incomplète par exemple sur du
matériel quatre ans mais d'autres enjeux
également et qui était capable encore
aujourd'hui d'expliquer comment c'est
propre c'est précis pas le premier sou
engagements vont fonctionner ce soit les
maternelles quatre ans encore une fois
que ce soit la question d'énergie que ce
soit la question des immigrants et cette
malheureuse idée d'expulsion il ya
beaucoup d'obscurité du côté de la cac
alors je pense que les gens verront ça
et ils vont comparer alors messieurs
clair quand j'ai fait avec les autres
chefs je souhaite une bonne fin de
campagne
vous êtes gentils ma gueule pour vie
elle veut revoir
m
[Musique]